>> A FIFTH INSTALLMENT OF
"INDIANA JONES" IS COMING SOON
AND AN EMOTIONAL HARRISON
INTRODUCED THE FINAL CHAPTER AT
THE D-23 EXPO.
>> "INDIANA JONES" MOVIES ARE
ABOUT MYSTERY AND ADVENTURE, BUT
THEY'RE ALSO ABOUT HEART.
AND WE HAVE -- WE HAVE A REALLY
HUMAN STORY TO TELL.
>> GETTING EMOTIONAL SEEING
HARRISON FORD GET EMOTIONAL.
HARRY, LET'S TALK ABOUT "INDIANA
JONES" BY THE NUMBERS HERE.
AS A FRANCHISE HOW DOES IT
COMPARE TO OTHER FILM
FRANCHISES?
>> OKAY.
IF THERE'S ONE THING ABOUT
INDIANA JONES YOU SHOULD KNOW IS
THAT IT MAKES A LOT OF MONEY.
THIS IS THE AVERAGE DOMESTIC
GROWTH AMONG FRANCHISES WITH
THREE OR MORE FILMS.
INDIANA JONES, NUMBER THREE WITH
319 MILLION PER FILMS.
AVENGERS AHEAD OF IT, STAR WARS
AHEAD OF IT BUT NOTHING ELSE.
519 MILLION OVER FOUR FILMS OVER
MULTIPLE DECADES.
THAT JOHN, IS REALLY IMPRESSIVE.
>> A LOT OF MONEY THERE.
HOW ABOUT THE CRITICAL ACCLAIM?
>> NOTICE THOSE FILMS ON THE
LIST.
NOT REALLY ON THIS LIST.
WHAT "INDIANA JONES" DOES THAT'S
SO UNIQUE, NOT ONLY MAKES A TON
OF MONEY BUT THE CRITICS LOVE
IT.
THIS IS THE HIGHEST ROTTEN
TOMATOES FOR FRANCHISES.
AND WHAT WE ESSENTIALLY SEE HERE
IS LOOK AT "INDIANA JONES" ON
AVERAGE, 86%.
THE AVERAGE RATING.
YOU AND I WERE TALKING
BEFOREHAND AND --
>> I WAS GOING TO SAY, I THINK
THE NOSTALGIA FOR "INDIANA
JONES" IGNORES THE FACT THAT
INDIANA JONES AND THE CRYSTAL
SKULL EXISTED.
>> YOU CAN DENY IT ALL YOU WANT,
BUT EVEN WITH THE FILM IN THERE,
86%.
SO EVEN WITH THE JOHN BERMAN
WORST AWARD.
86% IS STILL THE AVERAGE, THAT'S
IMPRESSIVE OVER FOUR FILMS.
>> IT IS.
LET'S TALK ABOUT "INDIANA JONES"
BY THE NUMBERS, HARRISON FORD
HIMSELF.
>> WE HAVE THREE FINE LOOKING
GUYS UP HERE.
HARRISON FORD'S HISTORIC SPAN
STARRING AS INDIANA JONES.
HE APPEARED IN ALL THE FILMS.
A 42-YEAR SPAN.
THE SECOND LONGEST SPAN FOR A
STARRING ACTOR IN A TOP 50
DOMESTIC BOX OFFICE FRANCHISE.
ONLY STALLONE IN THE ROCKY FILMS
AND CREED FILMS BEATS HIM.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A FRANCHISE
ACCLAIMED AT THE BOX OFFICE AND
A STAR THAT HAS SHRED THE
SPACE/TIME CONTINUUM AND LOOKS
FANTASTIC.
>> HE DOES LOOK GREAT.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN OTHER PEOPLE
IN THE FILM.
>> THERE HAS.
HE HAS GREAT SUPPORTING CASTS.
LOOK AT THIS, ALL OSCAR NOMINEES
OR WINNERS.
>> NOT IN THIS FILM.
>> NO.
WE HAVE THE STAR HERE, I WAS
ANTICIPATED.
THEY WEREN'T NOMINATED FOR
INDIANA JONES BUT YOU CAN SEE
THE FOLKS.
ELLIOTT, RAIDERS OF THE LOST
ARK.
WE KNOW ANTONIO BANDERAS IS
GOING TO BE IN FIVE.
>> WHO WOULD YOU WANT TO BE.
>> IF YOU COULD LIVE IN A MOVIE
FOR ONE DAY, WHO WOULD YOU WANT
TO BE?
INDIANA JONES IS THE WINNER HERE
WITH 25%.
FERRIS BUELLER, I LIKE THAT.
>> IF YOU SAY DON IS THE GUY YOU
WANT TO BE, WHAT ARE YOU SAYING?
WHAT IS IT THAT YOU WANT TO DO?
>> COVER YOUR HEART HARRY, I'LL
LEAVE YOU WITH THAT.
APPRECIATE IT.
WELL DONE.